الى ملف الفساد الان معهد اتشاتم هاوس
البريطاني اشار الى ان احزاب ومجموعات
مسلحه تسيطر على قطاع الدواء العراقي
تقرير المعهد قال ان الدواء الذي كان من
المفترض ان يكون متوفرا في المستشفيات
الحكوميه يتم بيعه للقطاع الخاص مقابل
ارباح كجزء من منظومه جمعت المليارات من
الدولارات لحساب نوخ بن سياسيه ومجموعات
مسلحه على حساب ارواح العراقيين المعهد
فجر مفاجاه مفادها ان 30% فقط من الادويه
المتوفره في السوق العراقي صالحه
للاستهلاكه وتكون باهضه الثمن بينما
الادويه الاخرى المتوفره تكون مزوره او
منتهيه الصلاحيه ما ادى لوفاه الكثير من
المرضى اعتبر التقرير ان خصص توريد
الادويه للعراق ساهمت بشكل كبير في انتشار
هذا النوع من الفساد
لاعب بصحه العراقيين تقرير المعهد نقل عن
وزير صحه عراقي سابق قوله ان شبكات للتجار
في الادويه تحقق اربع خمس سنوات تتراوح
بين خمسه وسبعه مليار دولار جزء من
الارباح بحسب شتم هاوس يصل للاحزاب
والمجموعات المسلحه عن طريق تلقي الرشاوه
لتسهيل عبور الادويه وتفادي دفع اي رسوم
جمركيه هناك وجه اخر للازمه هو التهرب
الجمركي والضربي الذي يضيع على العراق نحو
عشره مليارات دولار اخرى
سنويا تحديدا ننتقل الى مراسلنا في بغداد
ليطلعنا على جانب من ازمه الادويه
[موسيقى]
نقص الادويه في العراق
الحكوميه عاجزه عن توفير قائمه طويله على
راسها ادويه مرضى السرطان الذي نباتوه
وجبرينا للبحث عنها في السوق السوداء
للحصول عليها باسعار باهظه جدا
بايش الادويه من بره غاليه ب 50 وب 40 و
60 و100 واحنا احنا ناس ما عندك القطاع
الخاص
80% من سوق العقاقير الطبيه في العراق
والتي يدخل معظمها الى داخل البلاد بطرق
غير قانونيه
هذا الاحتكار ادى الى وفاه العشرات يوميا
في المستشفيات
بسبب ارتفاع اسعار هذه العقاقير ومع الاسف
على حكومه اللي عدم المتابعه للصيدليات
وازيد الناس تعبانه
والمستشفيات عدم توفر الدواء بيها
فالمواطن وين يطر يروح يطري يروح علما
للخاص رغم حملات التفتيش التي نفذتها
وزاره الصحه والاجهزه الامنيه لعدد من
مداخر الادويه والصيدليات التي تحتقر بعض
العقاقير الطبيه الضروريه الا ان ذلك لم
يوفر حلا لهذه المشكله ولم يوفر الدواء
لمحتاجين من بغداد منتظر الرشيد العربيه
كاميرا العربيه استطلعت اراء عينه من
الشارع العراقي وسالت المواطنين عما اذا
عانوا من صعوبه في الدواء سواء لناحيه
توفره او سعره وعادتنا
مكلف غالي يعني لا يتوفر لا مستشفيات
حكوميه ولا باهليه تجد كل المستشفيات
تعاني من نقص في الدواء ولا يوجد اكثر من
الدواء البسيطه المتعارف واللي براسيتول
او الكبليكس نشيل بسيط اللي ممكن تتناوله
بالف دينار لكن هناك ادويه صعبه همم
يعني اسعارها عاليه اي مسائل موجوده عندنا
بداخل البلد صارت طبيعي المساله المساله
التجاره بس احنا اليوم نتامل انه لاشخاص
الموجودين بهذا المكان انه ياخذون هذا
الموضوع نضع الاحتبار لسبب واحد ان هم
مطلعين عليهم هم عايشين داخل هذا البلد
احنا اليوم نريد مساله الدواء لكل الطبقات
بالنسبه للمستشفيات يعني علاج ما بيها
نهائيا قطعا ما بها سعر الباص ثلاثه الاف
عيني والعلاج تشتريه من السوق انت ماكو
واحد اشترى علاج اليوم بالمستشفى